um there's going to be an awful lot of
buses that we're going to see open-sided
double-decker buses which we'll be
seeing um momentarily as as the um
parade
progresses
and uh lucky ashish is on the 1960s boss
we spoke to sir cliff richard earley
he's on the 50s boss um
and she she's on the 60s boss with the
likes of alan titchmarsh anthea turner
and basil brush
hi sheesh
okay yes exactly i'm standing next allen
touched marsh and kate garraway and
anthony turner you can see basil brush
his tail possibly right at the end i
will
make my way through the top deck of this
bus but let me just tell you about the
procession itself uh seven buses seven
decades
and each decade significant for culture
fashion music and there's been one
constant in all of those 70 years and
that is the queen and that's who we're
here to celebrate and honor let's talk
to some of the celebrities who are on
this bus
thank you that's very high that's very
kind sorry who are you no no no
let's talk to alan titchmarch
mbe
thank you guys
how are you enjoying this so far this is
phenomenal isn't it slightly surreal i
mean your your life flashes before you
plus it's from 56 to 73. why i'm on the
60s but i don't know it's not telling
from the symptoms but i'm not being
picky it's a chance to see all the
people that you've loved growing up with
the all three life wonderful there's a
great atmosphere to it do you know what
i've been really struck by you're all so
excited you're taking selfies and
photographs and waving at people this is
incredible to just be here and be part
of this occasion
are
isn't
up every single moment of this this is
this is precious we said it it's our
it's a real sunday
it really is and when we get home we've
got to remember everything and alan said
you're going to write it all down write
down everybody you saw i think we've all
been invited to tell them this is it
it's been lovely thank you very much for
sharing but not at all thank you can i
ask you how do you like being referred
to as a national treasure i have spent
my life dreaming of such a thing to be
honest and i cannot believe it but we
arrived very early in the morning it was
supposed to say natural treasures i was
like this is it the moment has arrived
i'm so excited yeah i love it i love it
i mean i know there's some people that
find it maybe makes you sound a little
bit old
it makes me feel so now i'm at least the
national treasure apparently i'm an
imposter so i'm calling myself national
trinkets
you're a broadcaster but you're also one
of the nation's best loved gardeners
what advice would you give to the queen
about her garden she's she's into her
gardening isn't she i don't think she
needs any advice from me she knows much
more than you would imagine and she
loves being out there favorite flower
lily of the valley i wouldn't dream of
telling her anything
she's been on gardens i've met at
chelsea flower show and said oh i like
your eye legs
good and what's been your favorite
moment of the past few days what's
really stood out for me
last night the concert last night i will
never see on my television screen
unfortunately i wasn't here but it was
off the scale awesome awesome awesome
and what about you kate what's been your
highlight so far the whole thing has
been wonderful and it just reminds you
how lucky we are to have to be and what
a special thing she's done and to be
able to be part of it which i think
everyone has in a way we had a little
street party yesterday at home and that
was fantastic and now we're here on the
biggest three party on the planet yeah
absolutely amazing we are lucky and
privileged to be part of this occasion
okay this this is going to take about 45
minutes i'm told
about three and a half kilometers a six
and a half thousand people taking part
as as
people who are taking part in the
procession itself so it's taken a lot of
work to put together
and and the bus can break look this is
william roach hello hello how are you
very well thank you for asking how are
you well we've only just started
are you enjoying yourself
this is a
unique occasion there's no question
about it and the best of the best of
everything from the guards and the
soldiers to the
you've got everything you could possibly
want today and the queen has done such a
wonderful time with her brain and this
is the unique the only monarch i think
ever in the world has done 70 years and
we're allowed to be here for that and
you're wearing a medal uh that's only
the mbe yeah i've got the obe actually
this year as well which is
very nice i met the queen for that so uh
hopefully i'll meet her again when i get
the other one you're very lucky william
thank you for talking to us yeah
pleasure so i will endeavor to make my
way down to the front of the bus late
and talk to a few more of the national
treasures who've been invited to take
part in this pageant today
okay
thanks very much indeed